La volta al món a peu, dia 279.
Suposo que la meva vestimenta respon a la pregunta d'ahir.
A veure, tota la nit, molt bé.
A la que he arribat a les 4 o 5 de la matinada,
dintre el sac estava bé, però notava que a fora feia una mica de fred, eh?
I ara pel matí he sortit amb això.
Mandra absoluta de sortir del sac de dormir perquè, buah,
feia...
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Una mica de fred, eh? I són les...
Vaig tard, són les 7 i pico.
Podria haver sortit molt abans, però...
Mandra increïble de sortir.
Bueno, igualment, doncs...
Ni tranquil·la.
Bona nit, com sempre.
I vinga, va.
Em poso a caminar ja, perquè si no...
Males notícies.
Se m'ha acabat la crema solar.
O si més no, queda molt poc.
L'he de ficar així, de cap per baix,
perquè surti.
Sí, sí, es veu que s'ha acabat.
Això fa i ho meu, eh?
L'hauria d'haver recarregat, comprat una nova a Jorok.
Però no sé per què vaig fer així i pensar que n'hi havia.
I aquest matí em vaig a posar i, bueno, complicat.
Dos opcions.
Una, intentar a la farmàcia,
o a d'altres farmàcies que trobi en el dia d'avui,
comprar-la.
Jo crec que a una farmàcia haurien de tenir crema de sol, no?
Jo hi crec.
Si veig que no en tenen,
la idea que he tingut és,
al final del dia,
a les 6,
o a la que sigui,
pillar un minibús d'aquests, un xàret taxi o el que sigui,
tornar a Jorok, comprar-la,
i intentar tornar al lloc d'estir,
o quedar-me a Jorok i el dia següent ja tornar a agafar un taxi.
Perquè ara és primordial la crema de sol.
És a dir, no sé si ho sabeu, però com més altura estàs,
més crema el sol.
Ara venen trams de 3.000, 4.000,
serà imprescindible la crema solar.
I no només això, sinó tapar-me el cos.
Tapar-me el cos.
Avui vaig amb pantalons llargs.
A veure com va.
A veure quant aguanto.
Potser estic tot el dia amb ells.
No ho sé.
En qualsevol cas,
obre a les 8,
la farmàcia, encara queden 5 minuts,
aquí hi ha un cafè,
doncs mira, aprofito per prendre alguna cosa i carregar la bateria.
Uno momento, diuen Zacarias,
que és el cuiner tan najo d'aquest restaurant.
A veure.
Ous amb salsitxes,
cafè amb llet,
i això que m'ha dit el nom dues vegades,
i no me'n recordo.
Uf, això té una pinta duríssima.
Té una pinta duríssima, això, eh?
Això sembla mantega.
Es muy mejor, tío, eh?
Vinga, va, això té una pinta duríssima, eh?
Ufa, vaig a provar-ho, va.
És un pèl dolç.
No m'agrada, però no és dolent, eh?
Simplement és que em...
Sembla papilla per nens, eh?
No és dolent, no és dolent.
Bueno, crec que avui no hi ha més restaurants,
per tant, aprofitaré.
Doncs no tenen, eh?
No tenen crema solar a dues farmàcies que hi ha aquí.
Això és bastant drama, eh?
Això és bastant, bastant drama, eh?
Bueno, buscaré algun supermercat si n'hi ha,
i si no hauré de tornar a Joroc, eh?
Hauré de tornar a Joroc.
Quina...
Que tonto, tio, és que...
Aquí hi ha un supermercat una mica
més modern que el típic market.
Sí, sí, sí. Això és molt més modern.
Si no hi ha aquí...
Si no hi ha aquí, no hi haurà enlloc.
A veure, aquesta és la zona dels cosmètics.
Aquí hi ha xampús.
Hi ha...
Hi ha de tot.
I aquí tenim... Això és desodorant, no?
Desodorant...
Això també és desodorant.
Crema de sol...
Això no sé què dimonis és.
No ho veig, eh? Crema de sol.
Li he dit crema de dents, volia dir.
No la veig pas, eh?
Sembla que no, eh?
Doncs no!
No en tenia, en el supermercat aquest.
Ja havia perdut tota esperança.
Li pregunto al noi, bueno, saps d'algun lloc on
ho pugui tenir? I diu, prova allà.
Ha, ha!
Visca! Visca!
En tenien dos, una de 15 i una de 50.
Evidentment, agafo la de 50.
Encara que és un pot petit, que és crema,
el que tenia fins ara
era així d'espray.
Bueno, és com més fàcil d'aplicar
per una superfície gran.
Però bueno...
En tenien un que posava 60
de protecció.
Dius, ostres, molt millor que 50, no?
Però valia molt més barat, sospitosament barat.
Valia 2,6 euros.
I em diu, aquest no és original.
This is original.
Bueno, pues espero que sigui original,
perquè si no
ho comproverem de seguida.
A veure, jo què sé.
Només pel packaging sembla bé.
Té com un certificat aquí.
No sé, bueno, fes-ho.
Vale.
Ja ho tenim, no he de tornar a Khorouk. Perfecte, tu.
Mira.
Pantalons curts, eh? No, al final.
Ni de conya tot el dia amb els pantalons ja, res fa calor.
Sota tot el sol,
pica. També,
muñeco de barro,
ja estic per seguir el dia.
El que és un espectacle de Tadjikistan
són les parades de bus,
que són soviètiques. Aquesta no té gaire
motius soviètics, però alguns tenen encara
la falça i el martell, eh?
Aquest, no sé molt bé què diu.
Hi ha aquí
un mapamundi.
Estem aquí.
La bandera de Tadjikistan
i algú diu aquí.
I això que mola molt.
Mola molt.
És que es nota que no ho han fet els tajiks, eh?
Perquè els tajiks no són molt artistes, eh?
No he vist jo gaires coses
així, amb una mica de
gràcia artística, eh? La capital
i alguna masquita
suelta, però molt
poc, eh? Bueno, no tenim repte
a Tadjikistan, eh?
Us ho vaig dir, eh? Propugeu-me
reptes i no em va acabar d'agradar tant.
Però mira, podem fer un repte
amb les parades d'autobús, no?
Potser no és el repte més
excitant, no?
Del món, precisament. Jo crec que no.
Però mira, queden
jo crec que uns 10 dies, no?
Va, 11.
Anem a intentar que el repte sigui
trobar 10 parades
d'autobús.
Aquesta no compta, val?
No una cada dia, perquè ja sé que hi ha dies que no en trobaré.
Però com a mínim 10, no?
No ho sé. Va.
Un repte absurd, però
per fer alguna cosa.
Atenció, perquè em para un ciclista i em diu
¿Tú eres el famoso catalán?
Hola, ¿cómo te llamas? Hola, ¿cómo va?
Mi nombre es Cristian, soy de Argentina
y bueno estoy recorriendo
el mundo en bicicleta.
Pues como yo. Claro, pero
un poco,
un poco en bicicleta. Capaz que es un poco
más rápido y no tan sacrificado
como caminar, que creo que es más
es más duro. Bueno, bueno.
Pero ¿cómo más conocido? Porque me lo estabas
explicando y te digo espera, espera que saco la cámara.
Hace unos días, dos días
atrás me quedé en los de
una familia, justo iba en bicicleta
y estaba buscando como un lugar
para pasar la noche. Entonces,
Entonces un señor me hace seña y me dice, aquí puedes acampar.
Todo con traductor porque tallico y ruso no hablamos.
Entonces me dice, si quieres eres invitado en nuestra casa.
Y bueno, estuve un rato ahí charlando y hace unos días estuvo un chico catalán
que está acá recorriendo el mundo en bicicleta.
Y yo digo, si va adelante, en algún momento me lo voy a encontrar,
salvo que sea la noche y ella haya parado a descansar.
Y cuando te vi caminando dije, ese debe ser...
Es el primero que he visto caminando, seguro.
Porque no he visto a nadie.
Acá no he visto a nadie, la verdad que no.
Era la casa de la profesora de inglés.
Sí, la casa de la profesora de inglés.
Ese sitio no es una guest house.
A mí me dijeron que era el primer extranjero que cogían de la historia.
Y se ve que ha quedado muy buena referencia porque me invitaron a mí.
Se lo pasaron bien y dijeron, venga.
Sí, sí, y la verdad que fue una charla súper linda,
la gente muy acogedora, como en todos lados, ¿no es cierto?
Entonces, nada.
Recordando ahí y charlando un poco de la cultura acá,
de lo que es esta parte de Tashikistán, claro, y Pamir.
Bueno, ¿cuándo saliste?
Uf, es una larga historia.
Salí desde Ushuaia, Argentina, en 2022.
¿2022?
Sí.
Hace cuatro años.
Hace cuatro años, aproximadamente.
Cuéntanos un poco tu trayecto hasta ahora.
Mi trayecto fue de Ushuaia a Cancún,
atravesando todo lo que era Argentina, Chile, Bolivia, toda Sudamérica.
Y de ahí a Centroamérica, hasta llegar a esa parte de...
Ecuador también, toda esa zona, la zona oeste, ¿no?
Claro, exactamente, como bordeando más por el Pacífico,
más por la cordillera de los Andes.
Después crucé en barco desde Colombia a Panamá.
Y de ahí se todo Centroamérica,
lo que fue Panamá, Costa Rica, Nicaragua, Honduras, Guatemala, Bélice.
Y llegué a Cancún.
Y de Cancún volé a Europa.
A Ámsterdam.
Y hice todo Europa Central y me fui a Europa del Este,
que sería Macedonia, Serbia, Kosovo...
No vas en línea recta, me entiendo, ¿no?
Vas dando por los países un poco...
Sí, voy también jugando un poco con el tema del espacio de Schengen,
al no tener...
Claro, al ser argentino, por ahí, con el pasaporte argentino,
tenemos 90 días para recorrer.
Entonces, como Europa del Este está fuera del espacio,
estuvo bueno hacer tiempo ahí.
Desde Albaña...
Sí, desde Albaña me fui hasta...
crucé en ferry para Italia y ahí subí desde Italia a Francia
hasta llegar a Andorra y me quedé hacer la temporada de invierno ahí.
Y después, desde Andorra retomé desde...
Me fui hasta Barcelona en bicicleta
y volé hasta Estambul.
Estambul hasta aquí mismo.
Hasta aquí.
Sí.
¿Has vuelto a Argentina?
He vuelto hace dos años y medio,
últimamente desde Colombia a Argentina para ver la familia
y yo creo que el año que viene va a tener que...
Va a tocar.
Va a tocar, sí.
¿Qué viene ahora?
Ahora viene a hacer todo lo que es Pamir,
terminar en Osh.
¿Kyrgyzstan?
Exactamente, Kyrgyzstan.
Creo que cruzaré a China
y de China volveré a Kazajistán para tomarme un vuelo de Almaty a Barcelona
y poder hacer de vuelta la temporada en Andorra,
parar un poquito.
Andorra, ¿eh?
Andorra... ¿Qué haces de Andorra?
¿Esquí o qué?
No, hotelería, restaurant, sí.
Andorra me ha tratado muy bien.
¿Entends el catalán?
No, no, por ahora, por el momento, no.
Pero prometo para el próximo vídeo que nos encontremos
alguna palabra va a salir.
Muy bien, muy bien.
Winter is coming.
¿Estás preparado por lo que viene ahora?
Porque vienen temperaturas un poco bajas a la zona del Pamir, ¿eh?
Exactamente.
Empezamos a subir ya en todo.
Lo bueno que es una subida paulatinamente,
entonces no pesa tanto.
Creo que llega hasta 4.660 en lo máximo.
Y bueno, habrá que... que abrigarse bien.
Veo que vas bastante ultraligero, me gusta.
He visto otros ciclistas que van muy, muy... con mucho equipaje, ¿eh?
Sí, esta, a ver, a medida del tiempo...
Es la que vas con chanclas.
Sí, es súper cómodo para viajar.
Tengo las zapatillas, pero en la temperatura,
cuando baja la temperatura, las zapatillas y las medias van a ser...
Y la calza larga va a ser fundamental.
Pero sí, estas antes las llevaba adelante,
y después traigo otra más grande hacia atrás.
Pero te terminás dando cuenta que necesitas muy poco para todos los días.
Claro, cuando llevas ya un tiempo, ya has perfeccionado mucho el equipaje, claro.
Exactamente, ya un poco más de experiencia,
ya te das cuenta qué cosas sirven, qué cosas no, entonces...
Bueno, cada vez que me encuentro algún viajante de este,
le hago las mismas preguntas.
De los dos años que llevas, ¿país preferido?
El país preferido...
O sea, donde has estado mejor, ¿no? Diríamos, donde has pasado mejor.
Sería muy injusto por ahí hablar de un solo país,
porque cada país te acoge de una manera increíble,
cada país tiene su cultura, su religión, sus costumbres,
pero para mí yo creo que Perú fue como un país que me marcó un antes y un después en...
Me alegra oír eso porque me habían dado referencias no tan positivas,
de Perú, otro ciclista que había ido por ahí.
Pero bueno, bien, bien, porque tengo ganas de ir a Perú, aún me queda mucho, por eso.
Perú es increíble.
La comida, su gente, las montañas,
vas atravesando por la cordillera de los Andes, la cordillera blanca,
y llegás a alturas de 5.000 metros de altura,
y la verdad que las vistas de allá son increíbles.
¿Peor país?
No hay peor país.
No se moja.
¿Mejor comida?
El enxucado, creo que se llamaba, en Ecuador,
que es como una sopa de pescado con yuca, con cebolla...
con perejil, con varias cosas, eso me gustó mucho.
¿Peor comida o peor país donde se come peor?
Hay una comida que no me gustó, la comí porque tenía mucho hambre,
y fue en Bolivia, comí burro.
No sabía que se comía esto.
Yo tampoco, pero era lo único, el plato del día era como burro,
y era otra cosa, que eran como unas bolas así, que eran muy secas,
y la verdad que no... estuvo bien para un día, para matar el hambre,
pero no lo volvería a repetir.
¿Mejor momento, o sea, un momento único ahí, ese momento que dices el mejor?
Seguramente cuando crucé desde Colombia a Panamá en un velero,
con la bicicleta, fui de voluntario,
y ver en 360 lo que era navegar por el Caribe y el agua turquesa,
fue increíble, y ver saltar delfines al lado, estilo película...
No me des ideas.
Esto es como... esto es como subreal.
Y para acabar, ¿peor momento?
El peor momento... no hubo... mucha gente se asombra,
pero no hubo una mala situación donde me han querido robar,
donde haya pasado mal momento...
Creo que tal vez...
Ecuador tiene como mala fama últimamente, que está un poco peligroso.
Por la costa supuestamente, pero yo me fui como por la zona de montaña,
y la gente es súper amable.
Quizá los peores momentos fue cuando te hayas podido quedar sin agua
en algún momento, calculado mal,
o haber estado descompuesto por alguna comida que te haya caído mal,
o el agua misma del lugar...
Eso puede ser el peor momento.
Pero con lo que es la gente, o haya tenido problemas con tráfico,
que me hayan chocado, golpeado, o algo... cero.
Por suerte, sigamos con la misma racha.
Perfecto. ¿Tienes redes?
Sí. No soy mucho de generar contenido,
pero subo fotos siempre, eventualmente.
Es cristian.r.schneider es mi nombre.
Lo vamos a poner aquí encima para que la gente lo vea.
Pues nada, pues hostia.
Hacía mucho tiempo que no hablaba castellano.
Yo también.
Yo también. Creo que desde Georgia,
que encontré una chica argentina y español, otra española,
que no hablaba, pero siempre es gratificante poder hablar
en tu idioma.
Muy bien, muy bien.
Mucha suerte.
Mucha suerte para vos también y saludos a todos los televidentes.
Ja s'ha anat el Christian.
M'ha estat una bona estona, tipo mitja hora o així,
caminant junts i xerrant de coses.
M'ha fet venir moltes ganes d'anar a Sudamèrica,
que allà hi havia d'anar, però
anava més també per Ecuador i Colòmbia.
Molt bé.
¿Us agraden aquestes entrevistes que faig a Aventurers que trobo?
Al final sempre són les mateixes preguntes.
I a vegades les respostes són diferents, a vegades són similars.
Feu-m'ho saber als comentaris, si us agrada.
Jo crec que està bé. Està bastant enriquidor.
El que passa és que, clar, si és constant,
entenc que pot avorrir, no? Però, bueno.
També és veritat que, clar,
o sigui, jo fins ara no m'havia trobat a ningú gairebé.
Si no recordeu, molt poca gent
m'havia trobat a la carretera fent
fent això, córregudes amb bicicleta o el que sigui,
i ara me n'he trobat uns quants.
Llavors, per això ara n'hi ha més.
Clar, normalment no n'hi ha cap.
Parada d'autobús.
La més lletja de tot el país.
Però parada d'autobús.
Una de deu. Queda en nou.
Les dues, vint-i-cinc quilòmetres, prou bé.
Avui no hi ha restaurant, malauradament.
Bueno, el del matí, no?
I m'he comprat res. Quatre merdes per
per fer un dinar, abrenar, així.
No tinc tanta gana perquè és morret fort.
Aquí, aquest paisatge cada cop més desolat, eh?
Estic a un poble, però cada cop
estan més juny
un dels altres, eh?
Vaig a menjar.
Reprenc la marxa bastant de vent
i com veieu
núvols, eh?
M'he ficat els pantalons jats una altra vegada.
I
segona parada d'autobús.
Dos de deu.
A veure, hi havia la possibilitat que plogués
avui, posava un 30% de possibilitat.
Jo no crec que plogui.
Però aquí, ara que se'n va el sol,
bufa més el vent
i, ostres, eh...
Tampoc diria que molta rasca,
però m'he posat el
paravent aquí fora per si l'he d'agafar
i posar-me'l i ja està.
De fet, ara me'l podria posar.
I això no és res
del fred que ha de venir, eh?
És que no és absolutament res
comparat amb el que ha de venir. Ai!
Molt de vent, molt de vent.
Quan surt el sol
tinc calor, tu, ara. Però quan
no surt
s'està bé amb el paravent aquest. Què?
Ja no recordàveu, eh?
Com era l'Enric
amb la vestimenta aquesta
blava i la caputxa.
Les tres i mitja
ja s'ha acabat el vent.
Bueno, normalment
a partir de les cinc de la tarda
o així, quan el sol es comença a posar,
torna a arrencar. Igualment,
els pantalons no me'ls trec.
Això d'anar-se a canviar els pantalons
és molt incòmode perquè m'atrola les sabates i tal.
Ei! Les cases
més maques
i amb el paisatge així més maco, jardinets,
estan aquí, eh? En aquesta
vall de Tajikistan que estic caminant.
Les cinc de la tarda
segueixo caminant.
Us he dit que a les cinc
tornava el vent. Doncs això.
A més, núvols.
A veure,
en els propers dies
la meteo, a part de les temperatures
que és una altra història,
pinta bé. Pinta així,
una mica de núvols durant una estona,
una mica de sol durant una estona,
i no marca molt de vent.
Suposo que
ja el vent habitual
del matí o d'això,
de la tarda o el que sigui, però
no marca gaire vent. Per tant,
crec que el tram que comencem de bar,
que és el tram Xungo,
en quina meteo com a mínim estaré bé.
Les sis de la tarda
ha parat el vent.
Mireu, porto quaranta-dos quilòmetres ja.
Aquí seria un genial
lloc per acampar.
Menjat per les vaques, hi ha herba baixa.
I a l'altra banda, bueno,
ara hi ha això, però també hi ha molts
llocs on està bé.
Però, bueno,
apuraré.
Apuraré fins a les sis i mitja, que és
més o menys quan se'n va el sol.
Sí, em sento fort.
Estic cansat, però
em sento fort i vull
apurar totes les hores de sol
per arribar abans a la Xina.
Sis i mitja,
he arribat aquí on volia.
Tenim
a la banda muntanya
uns camps que sí,
podrien ser interessants, sí.
Però també hi ha alguna
casa a aquella banda
i a la banda riu
doncs no hi ha res.
I a més hi ha en aquesta entrada,
per tant, mira, hi ha una antiga tanca
que està tancada, caiguda.
Ui, veig una mica de
aigua moix, eh?
Que no, ara la liem a última hora.
Saltet.
Doncs mira, està molt bé.
És pla. Jo crec que aquí hi van portar vaques.
Ara, bueno, sí,
perquè veig alguna tifa.
Ara és qüestió de trobar algun lloc
que, bueno, que segueixi sent pla,
que estigui un pèl més amagat
de la carretera.
I...
ja està, poc més.
Doncs molt bé aquest lloc.
Molt pla, a prop,
però no suficientment a prop
de la carretera.
No fa vent, important.
No fa vent, clar,
hi ha arbres al voltant, llavors em protegiria una mica.
I... sí, sí, sí.
I sec, sec.
Que el d'ahir estava un pèl humit i tenia la tenda
un pèl humida.
Avui ha sigut un molt bon dia, 44 km i mig.
He fet bastants quilòmetres.
Un cafè, un refresc,
que he parlat amb dues persones i m'he gastat
14 euros.
La crema de sal m'ha costat 6.
Un molt bon dia.
Els paisatges,
sobretot aquesta part final, han sigut brutals.
Han sigut brutals.
I el matí, també.
M'ha agradat, m'ha agradat.
A veure, avui també ha sigut un dia fàcil.
Que va ser clar, com que estic patint
pel que vindrà,
ja em poso en lo pitjor, no?
Un parell de moments de vent.
Parells de moment
d'un pèl de fred.
Però ja està, la resta ha sigut caminar per la Pamir.
No he hagut
ni pols, ni molt de trànsit.
He tingut aigua.
Ara no tinc aigua,
no he calculat bé i només em queda això suficient
i de sobres per passar la nit, eh?
Però no em podré rentar gaire
els peus, que normalment
m'agrada rentar-me'ls. No passa res.
Demà
se senten els camions que passen?
sí que surto de la Pamir
i demà
comença un tram
que
hi ha bastantes incògnites.
Sé que es pot fer.
Sí,
no hi ha cap dubte, però
hi ha incògnites respecte
al fred
i com serà el camí,
quants quilòmetres podré avançar,
quin serà el punt de
finalitzar, el punt de
acampada... No ho sé molt bé.
Però bé, jo crec que tinc aquest tipus
d'angoixa perquè, clar, porto tants dies caminant per carretera
que és tan fàcil que la que em poso
per un camí de senderisme ja... Ai, i no hauria
de ser així, no? No passa res.
No passa res.
A veure que tal la temperatura demà.
Ah, i per cert,
us vaig dir que
pujaríem fins als 3.000 metres.
Bé, la cota actual és
2.996.
O sigui que...
Gairebé, gairebé.
Molts nervis per demà
i per tot el que ha de venir,
però espero
que me'n surti i que sigui guapo. Bona nit.